Hikaru Nakamura 120 bullet chess games
in a row against his opponent Amin
Ohanian winning the first round of the
bullet Chess Championship 22 and a half
to one and a half the match started out
close with a score of two and a half to
one and a half for akaru but he quickly
pulled away winning game after game
after game
in a moment of desperation Amin tried a
sneaky trick known as the lafong trying
to catch his opponent in a pre-move but
Hikaru saw this and quickly took the
free piece as well as that game in chess
a player is said to have adopted their
opponent by winning 10 games in a row we
witnessed a double adoption because